[Musique]
le château de chémery que vous voyez
juste derrière moi a été construit à
partir du xiiie siècle et il a appartenu
à alain souchon jusqu'en 1981 et ensuite
axel fontaine l'a rachetée et depuis ils
leur tape petit à petit pour ça et
depuis trois ans il appelle des
bénévoles qui lui donne un coup de main
et aujourd'hui c'est le chantier de la
chaux
bonjour monsieur fontaine
avec moi vous avez un coup de main là
vous avez des gens dans votre château
pour vous aider aujourd'hui oui parce
que depuis trois ans on a mis en place
un chantier participatif
donc on a réussi à constituer une bonne
équipe je crois que tous on a toujours
plaisir à donner un petit coup de main
pour restaurer ce qu'on va dire cet
élément du patrimoine
moi je mets un point d'honneur à ce que
dans le
la mise en place de ce chantier bon soit
dans la transmission des savoir-faire on
prend le temps de bien faire les choses
on ne le fait pas forcément vite mais on
le fait bien
l'architecte et nous passe rien aux
critères soient des quais
qu'est ce que vous faites ici vous
pourquoi vous êtes là ébéniste c'est
vraiment la pièce est une erreur je sais
c'est pas du tout mon truc bon j'ai
aussi mais à la taille de pierre depuis
je suis à la restauration de ce lot de
chémery mais j'ai jamais jamais jamais
travailler la pierre mon arrivée ici oui
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît là dedans ah
bah c'est ce que je suis en train de
faire actuellement et puis restauré les
surtout les châteaux
l'ambiance est bonne il ya des bombes
des bons camarades de travail puis on
apprend des techniques mais on a un
grand chef qui nous apprend bien ça puis
voilà sinon c'est juste que pour le
plaisir et puis ça permet de se dépenser
comment vous avez entendu parler de ces
chantiers par mon fils mon fils vient
ici aussi samedi et puis
il m'en a parlé quoi plus du peu
pourquoi paul c'est comme ça qui fait
partie de l'association
h en train d'apprendre encore donc la
bombe ont fait à sous couche on appelle
2 go petit donc avant la couche finale à
la chaux grâce
parce qu'il plaît c'est d'apprendre des
choses nouvelles et puis datant d'une
ambiance sympathique se rendent utiles
c'est vraiment agréable de rendre
service à quelqu'un qu'il est il en vaut
la peine by après mm c'est nickel pour
quelqu'un qui est proche du métier oui
tu as le droit de revenir
a dit lula alors on a vu monsieur
fontaine que des bénévoles venez vous
aidez nous à les avoir à notre
partenariat pour vous aider je crois oui
on a mis établi un partenariat avec la
fondation d'auteuil ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les apprentis d'auteuil pour
mettre en place un chantier école qui va
commencer dès que j'aurai obtenu le
permis de construire est
je pense l'avoir pour le mois de
décembre est le champion va commencer en
avril et comme vous aimez bien la
restauration des vieux bâtiments vous
avez acheté une tour à blois et ça ya 20
ans vous savez tout ouïe en 99 on a
acheté là on s'est porté acquéreur de la
tour beauvoir blanc c'est le plus vieux
monument de doigts c'est la plus vieille
prison de france et c'est un donjon de
la fin du xième siècle dans laquelle
nous avons aménagé des cachots d'hôtes
est ce que je vous propose c'est que
vous allez vous changer et puis on se
retrouve là bas juste après d'accord à
tout à l'heure talât
[Musique]
c'est encore d'où
là vous êtes dans le plus vieux monument
doit qu'on appelle la tour beauvoir
c'est un donjon de la fin du xième
siècle qui appartenait à l'époque au
seigneur de beauvoir qui avait un fief
qui allait donc de la tour jusqu'à la
loire
alors en la transformer en cachot
d'hôtes chaque cellule a une fonction la
première qu'on va voir c'est le cachot
pour les enfants donc à deux lits
simples la deuxième c'est le coin un
petit déjeuner kitschnette pour prendre
un repas la troisième c'est la salle
d'eau la quatrième c'est le coin
parentale avec un lit double
la cinquième ou on va dire que c'est la
seule prison de france qui est un coin
séjour puisque le cinquième cas chose
c'est un con on peut se reposer
comme cet animé ici il n'y avait rien
pas d'eau pas d'électricité pas d'eau
pas d'électricité pas de rapport au tout
à l'égout et donc combien ça vous a
coûté tout ça entre l'achat et la
restauration cette tour le lâcha nous a
coûté quinze mille euros donc c'est pas
excessif
et la restauration on a investi
je crois qu'il 48 lots ont quand même
con con amorti justement à la location
des cachots alors on monte à la terrasse
[Musique]
on vient de monter 120 marche pour
profiter de la plus belle vue de voir
dans tout à fait oui on est sur la
terrasse une vue périphérique
360° avec devant nous le la ville
ancienne de blanc va dire derrière nous
c'était hors fortifications et c'est
rare de la voir tout autour de nous tout
entièrement panoramique oui on est plus
bas que la cathédrale saint-louis là bas
mais on n'a pas la vue panoramique sur
la cathédrale là ici on a eu 360 degrés
merci nous avoir reçu dans votre château
et dans votre tour merci aussi au revoir
[Musique]